As with privacy consent, there
are several data segmentation models.
A completely patient controlled
model is the norm for PHRs,
where there is no obvious alternative
other than a friend or family member
who may be more familiar with medical
terminology than the patient.
We mentioned a Provider Assisted Model,
but
this does require that busy
providers spend time on the task.
And even if they are willing, this may
not work well if the patient's data is,
as is often the case,
spread among a number of providers.
There are other approaches, including
Organization Controlled Models,
Hybrid Models and Innovative Tools.
That are typically aimed at providing
patients with more support.
All of these ultimately try to simplify
the complexity in the underlying
clinical data, which in turn relies on
better structures than are typically
found in today's EHRs.